كعادته يحب الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب ان يحدث الجلبه بتصريحاته وافعاله
احداثها ما نشره على منصه تروس سوش
القائله ان الاحتلال والخداع من هذا النوع
على نطاق واسع يمكن من الغاء او يمكن من
الغاء جميع القواعد والوائح والمواد مما
في ذلك تلك الوارده في الدستور تصريح
استنكره البيت الابيض قبل ان يلقي بالترمب
في مرمى انتقادات السياسيين الامريكيين
الذين ذهبوا بعضهم لوصفي ما فعله كما يطلق
النار على قدميه البعض منهم اعتبر ان
ترامب بفعلته هذه يبدو وكانه يدق المسامير
الاخيره في نعش ترشحه الرئاسه عام 2024
فهو ببساطه يعلن هجوما علنيا على
الديمقراطيه المتحدث باسم البيت الابيض
اندروبيت شدد في بيانيه على اهميه دستور
الولايات المتحده وقال انه هو ثقه مقدسه
تكفى او تكفل منذ عام الحريه وسياده
القانون في بلدنا الجميله واضاف ان مهاجمه
الدستور وكل ما يمثله مناقد لروحه لروحي
بلادنا ويجب ادانتها وتابع لا يمكنك ان
تحب امريكا فقط عندما تفوز زعيم
الديمقراطيين في مجلس الشيوخ تشاك شومر
ابدا اسياؤه ايضا من ترامب الذي طورت
الاسبوع الماضي في مادبه عشاء مع معادين
للساميه حضرها نيك فويس
الذي ينكر الهول كوست ومغني كاني واستا
والان يدعو الى انهاء الديمقراطيه
الدستوريه في امريكا على حد تعم- تعبير
كما ادانا جون بالتل مستشار الامن القومي
السابق ترامب واوضح انه يجب على الجميع
جميع المحافظين الحقيقيين معارضته همم في
انتخابات عام 2024 وانا قلت نيويورك تايمز
عن النائب الجمهوري المنتخب
الامريكي وليس لكن جمهوريين اخرين التزم
ومن بينهم كفن مقارتي زعيم الاقليه
لجمهوريه في مجلس النواب الذي يعمل في ان
يصبح رئيسا للمجلس بعد حصول الحزب على
الاغلبيه
همم
ترامب مروع انه غير قانوني ليس هناك سابقه
مثلها في التاريخ الامريكي لقد صدمت
لانهما يزال شخصيه محترمه ويدعمه العديد
من الجمهوريين
لم احب ترامب ابدا ولذلك فان كل ما يقوله
لا يهم على الاطلاق
لا اعتقد ان ما قاله صحيحا الناس صوته
الرئيس الصحيح في منصبه الان وترامب كان
خطا فادح
اذا ابتعدنا
للولايات المتحده سنتخلى عن هويتي لذلك
اعتقد ان ترامب يحاول ان يدافع عن جدته
الخاصه وهذا هو الحل دائما يمكن ان نرى من
خلال كل الايام المجنونه لاداراته عندما
يهمه هو جندته فقط